on m'a demandé ce que ce serait que la
pédagogie
[Musique]
et bien c'est par là que nous allons
terminer
tout a toujours une fin et chacun se
termine
au moment ce n'est pas le cas
[Musique]
de toute façon
après de gaulle c'est peut-être ce soir
ou dans six mois ou dans un an
ça peut être dans cinq ans
puisque c'est là le terme que fixe à
comps solution au mandat qui est confié
mais
si vous voulez faire rire quelques-uns
ou en faire broyer d'autres je dirais
que ça peut aussi bien durer encore dix
ans quinze ans
franchement je ne le pense pas qu'est-ce
que d'euros de gaulle aurait pensé de
ceux qui se prétendent ses héritiers
parce que lui semble considérer que
après lui finalement
il se passera pas grand chose y aura pas
grand chose il ne peut pas en avoir
parce que personne ne peut égaler cette
grandeur et cette force en revanche
est d'ailleurs ceux qui s'en réclament
souvent sont ceux qui l'ont plus le plus
trahis dans les faits et notamment le
parti dit gaulliste qui était le rpr
puis l'ump donc là dessus c'est pourquoi
j'en suis parti mais pour autant je
pense qu'on a quand même le droit de
tirer les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
non pas pour imiter mais simplement pour
en tirer les leçons il ya quelques
points cardinaux pour moi il y en a
quatre l'esprit de résistance on doit
pouvoir tout abandonner pour une
conviction le deuxième point c'est la
souveraineté du peuple c'est le peuple
qui doit décider c'est pas les
oligarchies nous sommes en oligarchie
aujourd'hui troisième point c'est un
humanisme
nimani c'est à dire c'est pas la france
pour la france c'est ce que je vous dis
au départ d'ailleurs c'est la france
d'égalité sociale la participation sept
grands échecs de de gaulle parce que les
syndicales patronales l'ont tué
et puis et puis c'est le quatrième point
qui va vous surprendre c'est une vision
de l'avenir c'est à dire que c'était un
géant parce qu'il avait une anticipation
notamment par exemple sur ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui et l'ukraine sur la mule un
monde multipolaire c'est à dire des
grands blocs la chine etc et nous on est
revenu dans l'alliance atlantique on
s'est rétréci au moment où devrait
épouser le monde avec la francophonie
voilà pour moi c'est ça le gaullisme
alors ça s'appellera autrement si un
jour il ya un homme d'état en france
voilà qui arrive au pouvoir parce que le
problème le problème c'est comme
aujourd'hui c'est comme si on demandait
à de gaulle de se faire élire par vichy
c'est assez dur en fait on demande aux
gaullistes de se faire élire dans le
régime de vichy c'est pas facile c'est
le régime de vichy aujourd'hui pas la
même chose mais dans l'esprit
c'est un esprit d'abandon la france les
dirigeants français sont devenus des
ligue arc qui ont abandonné
l'indépendance du pays je le pense et
quand ça a été pareil sous les anglais
sous jeanne d'arc enfin quand jeanne
d'arc combattait ça a été paré de tous
ces régimes où les dirigeants sont
vendus à l'étranger voilà moi j'estime
que nos dirigeants ont vendu le pays à
l'étranger voilà donc je vous le dis
comme je le pense alors plus ou moins
alors on peut le vendre pour de l'argent
on peut le vendre pour une idéologie
abominable 7 est vicié c'était bien pire
attention ne mélangez pas mais c'est cet
esprit de la soumission on ne défend
plus l'intérêt du peuple on défend des
privilèges et des oligarques c'est la
france macro nist
[Musique]